thank you so much for joining us today
welcome to the rstudio
enterprise community meetup
i'm rachel dempsey i'm calling in from
the r studio office in boston today
today we are streaming out to linkedin
and youtube live
if you have just joined now feel free to
introduce yourselves through the chat
window and say hello maybe where you're
calling in from
for anybody who's joining this group for
the first time a special welcome to you
we're so happy to to have you here with
us today
if you are joining for the first time
this is a friendly and open meetup
environment for teams to share the work
they're doing within their organizations
teach lessons learned
network with each other
and really just allow us all to learn
from each other
thank you all so much for making this a
welcoming community
we really want to create a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
i like to reiterate that we love to hear
from everyone no matter your level of
experience or the industry that you work
in as well
while you can ask questions on whichever
platform you're watching from
you can also ask questions anonymously
through the slido link which i'll pull
up on the screen here
in just a second
there we go
but we are so excited to have so many
members of the pharma community here to
join us today as well
so i'd love to use this opportunity to
share some information about a few other
pharma communities and resources that
exist today and i have my colleague here
phil bauscher joining us and i'll pull
him on stage here as well
hey phil hey how's it going
good how are you doing good excited for
the session today
absolutely yeah it feels while we have
everybody here today i thought it'd be
great to just
share a little bit more about some of
the
pharma communities that exist today and
resources that are out there
yeah yeah totally so um a lot of
exciting things happening in the
community we have the work um through r
and pharma
uh we have things through your champion
page which is fantastic for people that
are setting up environments
uh we also have a lot of exciting
packages that are coming out of the
pharmaverse right now in the in the
pharma ecosystem so
yeah lots of lots of new exciting things
in the in the ecosystem so
that's awesome
well thanks phil phil's going to be here
hanging out and helping me behind the
scenes as well to help with some of the
questions coming in
um but
glad glad to have you all here today
so for today's meetup we are really
excited to be joined by action michottie
hossein senior principal scientist at
bristol-myers squibb who will be sharing
their data science framework for data
collaborations
and as mentioned earlier we will have
time for q a as well so you can put
those questions into wherever you're
watching from or use the slido link as
well for anonymous questions
but with that thank you all again for
joining us it's amazing to see such a
great group of people here and so many
familiar names popping up
on the screen so love to
to get to connect with you in the chat
as well
but with that i'd love to turn it over
to our speaker for today's meetup action
and i'll send phil and i backstage here
option and pull you on sounds great yeah
thanks a lot rachel thanks phil
uh hi everyone my name is abshin the
shady hussein and as rachel mentioned
i'm from bristol myers quick
um
before going further i wanted to again
thank the
rstudio pharma meetup community and and
organizers uh particularly rachel uh and
phil here uh for giving me the
opportunity to share with you all data
as a product a data science framework
for data collaborations
this is a work that uh
my co-authors and i julie rudlowski
garth mcgrath and i
presented
to r in pharma back
in late 2021
so the hope in presenting it again and
sharing it here again
is that
we have a little bit more time for
uh more of a discussion and and the
question and answer
and hopefully
some of those conversations will benefit
from the experiences that we have
accumulated
since that
presentation last last year
um
so
to start things off i think it's quite
critical to
provide a definition of data product and
data as a product
if you have heard of this term uh you
might have noticed that in different
circles uh in different groups it could
mean quite different uh concepts
uh how we are defining uh data product
uh is simply a data object
that much like any other product
come with a set of characteristics or
attributes
so
specifically
we call
data product this uh this notion of data
product to be a data object that is use
case driven uh this is in contrast with
a quote-unquote wrangle data that can
serve any purpose it's clean data and
you can use it for whatever purpose so
this has to be the data product has to
have a specific user story or set of
coherence objectives that it achieves
now
if you have that level of a specificity
you can imagine that you may have
slightly different use cases leading to
a variety of different
data objects so it becomes even more
critical to be able to version control
it and track it so as you have
different slightly different data sets
you should be able to branch it you
should be able to version track it so uh
making it use cases specific and being
able then to kind of branch it and
version track it becomes quite critical
it needs to be tested
it needs to be
reproducible and i would say not only
reproducible but
easily reproducible meaning that with a
handful of commands you can just
reproduce the data
it should be easily maintainable
extensible think about this as uh your
typical r package in this context right
so in this context of our users
you can use in our package for whatever
end that you have in your analysis or
otherwise you can also use that to
integrate it into a new r package and
build upon it and extend it
same should apply to data products you
should be able to integrate it into a
new data product build a few of bring a
few of them together build upon them
extend them so it should be extensible
fine it should be findable accessible
and portable and
note on that last one is that as data
scientists
if i may speak for for for for that for
a lot of us that we may not necessarily
be super conscious or or or uh
uh
have concerns about whether my data is
coming from azure or or aws s3 or
whatever platform whatever
infrastructure i have
but you know our colleagues in it or
other places they may
so as my data as the requirements of my
organization changes i need to take my
data from
let's say aws s3 to azure or vice versa
or to some some network drive all of
this characteristic that we talked about
should go along so it shouldn't be
something that is dependent on the
platform or technology outside of the
data product uh this core set of
features there could be other features
that are dependent on on the platform uh
so this is this course of
characteristics and attributes uh
define uh that's an um
what we call a data product now data as
a product uh is a framework uh to make
it practical for data science teams to
pull together their data wrangling
efforts towards collaboratively building
data products so on one hand we have uh
this uh
product on the other hand we have a set
of processes that allows us to
easily uh or at least methodically build
these data products
so the processes could be
agreements between the teams like how we
want to like uh you know
use that you know kind of the
conventions of coding uh as well as some
automations and tools that allow us to
implement
those agreements so data as a product
you can think about as a framework way
of thinking uh and as well as the tool
sets that allow us to implement that way
of thinking data product is the output
so with that out of the way um as far as
the definition goes uh looking at these
attributes uh perhaps it's not difficult
to imagine a variety of motivations why
a data science team
may be interested in adopting a
framework that
will lead to their data sets or data
objects coming out
with all of these attributes but to
focus on one perhaps you can think about
this 80 20 rule of data science which
is basically this observation made by a
lot of the data scientists uh that uh
a typical week could involve four
days out of that five uh working uh days
uh
that you're engaged in data processing
uh or data wrangling whatever uh you you
call it uh and then on that last day you
may get get a chance to actually do your
data analysis so if uh as a data
scientist or uh or you know leader of a
data science team if you are interested
in adding more agility uh to
um
to the uh
you know to your overall um
you know team efforts uh it is fair to
look at this data processing uh and and
try to bring in additional uh agility to
it and an efficiency to it and there are
a variety of uh
approaches and and uh that teams have
implemented hopefully we all work in
teams that
uh heroic data wrangling is not one of
those approaches no one is advocating
for uh shrinking that you know 80
percent to you know 30 percent by just
willpower
and and working you know extra hours uh
hopefully that is not the case
but then there are things like new data
agreements that you may put in place
with data vendors you may ask your data
platform to do more in the way of data
validation
even pushing that validation of data
further upstream into your pipelines
that could help
in some cases it may seem appealing or
may be appealing to
extend the capacity of your data science
team if the resource is limited within
the data science team to extend the
capacity of the data science team by
bringing additional resources that could
then help with just the task of uh
building data however
one caveat around that is uh
particularly in the case of uh
you know pharma you can think about how
much domain knowledge and expertise is
uh
needed
and it gets factored in as we are
processing the data so science and
context can be missed
and so that is a caveat but setting that
aside these ideas and similar approaches
uh
collectively perhaps uh provide some
level of relief
um
perhaps a slightly different uh view
would be uh rather than seeking relief
uh we can acknowledge that here's my
team is spending their precious time and
resources and expertise i should
emphasize that expertise part
building
something
so there's a lot of value in that if 80
percent of my team is building this you
know artifact or output
that has a lot of value in it so
instead of thinking about or along the
way of thinking about reducing that uh
time to getting that can i also think
about
how can i
drive more value from this precious
resource
and
if if i'm thinking in that sense i'm not
trying to remove uh the burden uh of uh
of this effort
i'm just trying to drive more value from
it but to
alleviate that burden uh help with that
i can also make collaboration easy so
the big lift is shared
across the team
so it becomes a little bit easier so you
make collaboration easy when uh
permissible you can you can add a dash
of automated standards uh and uh make uh
build put in place processes uh uh uh
process frameworks for collaboration so
uh not surprisingly perhaps at this
point you you can imagine that this
latter approach of driving more value
from from data wrangling is uh
what uh the framework of data as a
product as we are defining it advocates
so the idea is that you're bringing your
usual input data
and you're adding your logic of data
wrangling and then you feed it into this
process that out would come a data
product
which then
can be fed into a number of utilities
analysis apps automated reports and this
data product now is reusable and
extensible so
that that work is essentially something
that lives on that in contrast with a
typical
of workflow of a data scientist which
may include uh data wrangling be so
inseparably intertangled with your
utility bit analysis or otherwise that
once that analysis is done or once that
utility has run its course then that
piece of
data work is essentially disposable so
you have an expensive very very
expensive effort that now has no no more
no more use
uh so up to this point we have talked
about this notion of data product in uh
abstract so let's
let's think about what's our north star
what are we aiming for here so
as i alluded to earlier it has to serve
a coherent set of objectives so this is
one of the core requirements again
thinking about any product out there you
know if you have a vacuum cleaner um
it's not going to be a you know hair
dryer or or you know iron right so it
has to have a coherent set of uh
objectives um
so that limits the
uh
the scope of the of the the effort even
with a limited scope you don't want to
be building it from a to z all in one
shot so uh think about it again a
product like you know you may have
different components that you build and
you assemble so it has to be built
modularly
um and if you are building it modularly
and your body here is building some
parts and you are building some parts of
it and you're bringing it all together
uh it should be something that while not
totally uh
you know
setting a stone that you're doing
exactly this way it has to have it
shouldn't be something that is an art
and everybody does it their own way so
collaboration requires some blueprint of
how we are building these uh elements
now again collaboration requires
everything to be version so we don't get
tangled up in uh you know what version
of what elements we are talking about
across a team
so by everything here i mean code
environment and data needs to be version
so all of the things that i've talked
about so far
as far as the requirements of the
product has to do with the build process
but from the user perspective it also
has to be easy to use so connect list
get is all you need to be able to
pull the data down and and use it so as
a user you should have an easy interface
and lastly as i mentioned we want to
have it be planned for agnostic so if
you're going from s3
later on you need to go to file systems
and r studio connect is your next
destination uh the data science
workforce should dictate where your data
is
or if there are other requirements
that that can be accommodated and you
don't have to worry about the
functionality of your data product being
compromised
now this is the product requirement and
there should be a build tool that can
enable building that uh product
according to those attributes so
uh it's you can see the linkage here
that
the build tool given all those
attributes that i mentioned are
requirements to naturally support
modular development should minimize
boilerplate uh should enable
reproducibility by capturing everything
in
the state of the code data and
environment
should encourage best uh code style
practices
should enable full traceability of
everything code data environment and as
a builder you should not be learning a
new language if you know r if you're not
git you should be good to go now if this
was instead of a data as a product this
was software as a product
uh you would uh
you know rightly expect that this tool
is already uh around and the in the
rich uh set of uh tools uh and
experiences and processes that have been
developed and
deployed implemented by
devops community when we are talking
about the software we can accommodate
all of those uh
features of a build tool
the difference here is that
not only we have code but we have data
so this gives us an inspiration that if
we were able to capture data as code we
would then build a bridge to this
rich
set of tools and and experiences that
are available uh in the devops community
uh and put those
to use for our end so
building with data as a code what's the
uh what's the approach here so thinking
about the concept there so let me walk
through an example
uh of how this could work conceptually
so let's say you are here in this uh you
know point one you have some data set
some of you in pharma are familiar with
this newman culture so let's say you
have some lb data which is this lab data
collected on a cohort of patients you
have some medication data uh and a bunch
more data sets that you have at your
disposal
now you start your project you you set
the initialization in motion it starts
kit it starts
capturing the environments that you're
developing in it uh adds the remote
locations for your code for your data uh
so that initialization is done now you
go ahead and onboard your data into into
your data product so let's start with
this lb which is this collection of lab
measurements on the cohorts of patients
you have
and so you bring that in and let's say
you can now sync that to your remote
location which you have already defined
at the initialization so at this stage
this is the part that perhaps worth
attention is that
you can capture this data
that you're pushing to a remote location
with a set of metadata in a way that
uniquely identifies that so you are
adding uh you're capturing some metadata
like the label for that data like some
description and this version uh which
could be essentially a shaw hash of that
data or any other flavor of getting some
sort of a hash for that data uniquely
identifies that data sense and
some additional set of metadata that
then will help you
retrieve this data if when you have the
need for it so now you have converted
your data to a set of metadata that
uniquely identifies and gives some
description about that data and if you
capture that
as you repeat adding additional data
sets you build a manifest that has all
the information you need for your input
data
and that is the approach of converting
data to code then as you add additional
layers of code for logic and and you're
capturing your environment all of this
is code you can commit it you can push
it and
when you have done that pushing
in your remote github repository now you
have the build logic you have the
package dependency and you have all the
information you need
uh to identify the input data
now
this recipe is complete in a way that a
colleague sitting at this point for or
maybe a cicd machine that gets triggered
uh by by the push
sitting
downstream can build this from a scratch
and push it again to the same remote
data repository in the same fashion
capturing the same set of metadata now
everything here has been converted into
code so your data lives in its data
location your code lives in the code
location and as long as you have access
to both you can build it from scratch
we have implemented this uh framework uh
uh
in r uh so it's a family of our packages
we call
dapper uh and uh
it is it is available for uh for use to
build uh essentially implement the the
framework that i just uh shared with you
all so this family of package uh uh
consists of three three packages uh dpi
dp deploy dp build uh why three packages
you may ask
i can come up with a couple of different
answers historically and in terms of the
bulk and code management but perhaps the
most important one is that you can think
about three different persona
that would be using these packages so
starting with dpi it means it's meant to
simplify access to data products
so if you're just a user
whether it's an application or a report
you only need a handful of functions to
be able to access the data products so
you don't need the bulk of the rest of
the packages
dp build is meant to simplify building
off data products
this is the bulkiest of the packages
this is used by the data developer so
you can think about the persona here is
the data developer dp deploy uh can be a
data developer
developer uh
or it can be a you know an automate a
workflow automation machine so you have
uh
this the task of dp deploys to simplify
sync and deployment of data products so
you can have a
you know kind of a ci cd processor set
up where you know as your data comes in
it gets pushed it's kind of like a
shuttling of the data from uh
location that is uh
you know some workstation to the remote
location
but how does uh so now that we've heard
about all of this how does this all come
together um
there are a variety of uh workflows that
uh
you know dapper needs to accommodate
like when you write code you don't
always start from setting up your
project and going all the way to
deployment
so you may set up your project develop
some you know go you know do something
else come back
you know have some uh pull requests
coming your way you know change that you
know deploy
so there's a lot of different uh
workflows that needs to be accommodated
but perhaps to just kind of provide an
end-to-end example if you were to start
from a beginning and go to the end it
would look something like this so you
start with that uh dp in it which is it
sets up your project uh it's kind of
like you know when you do get in it so
it just sets up your project uh you add
your data so you onboard your data uh we
are again encouraging best practices we
are encouraging folks to spend a little
bit of time here making sure the data
that they're onboarding is actually what
they want to onboard
then you add your logic
of the code and then you deploy the code
and data so at this point
essentially
everything has been put out there data
and code for anyone to be able to anyone
who has access and be granted access to
be able to access the code
and access the data now
what i want to emphasize here is that
this step is you know adding your code
uh is the step that should take the
bulk of your time
whether you're or not you're using data
you need to spend some time developing
that logic of data processing so the
idea here is that if you let's say today
spend an hour on a particular project
or two hours on a particular project
just doing the data processing part
now bringing that into
the dapper framework you're adding maybe
five ten more minutes on top of that but
still the bulk of your effort remains
the same so the boiler plate should be
minimized
now this is the claim and we're going to
go through uh
example a toy example that hopefully
shows this the toy example is overly
simplistic admittedly
we are starting from the cars data set
and uh and if i recall correctly there
is uh
this data set uh uh comes with you know
number of cars and i believe uh there is
a column that uh
is about uh the distance from the point
that the car
uh or driver applies the brake and the
car starts i think that's the case
so that column is in british units and
let's say the user story that you have
asks you to convert that to a metric
unit overly simplistic
vignette and actually this vignette is
also in the in the vignette for the
package so if you wanted to check it out
more more closely
um
but
being overly simplistic is still the
wiring and setup of the project is
identical to a bigger project that may
be more realistic with tons of data and
tons of logic so looking going through
that hopefully give us a sense of
what's the what's the degree of
boilerplate and the time that we need to
allow for that so we start with this uh
set up a step again thinking about all
the steps that i mentioned in the
previous setup data code deploy so we're
going to go through that so set up here
simply there's this function dp in it
that sets up your project folder runs
git in it
captures your environment thanks to rn
so it does the rn in it
adds remotes for code and data and
records project metadata so let's take a
look at how this looks uh in practice
so this video uh we are essentially
going through that initialization step
so we are bringing in the library
we are setting up some promises
for credential
that we need to access
we are not providing a credential to the
to the to the framework you're just
saying like these are the environment
variables you will need when you are
ready to build the data product
uh and we are putting that into into
into this uh dp unit we are also
providing the location of where the data
needs to go and then we execute this
dpinit so which takes in as parameters
some metadata you know what's the branch
name what's the project name what's the
user story what's the remote location
uh and and you know those promises
around uh
you know environment variables that will
be needed at the time of the day so
again here we have a single command
really at line 10 that sets up your
project
then we onboard the data and
in this case
we have a very simple
data set that we are onboarding but
in in general you can onboard any data
sets bundled together as zip or
otherwise into your data product one
thing i want to mention here is that
the notion of data product being
versioned
is that it is a snapshot so you may
start with live data but
you are snapshotting it at that point so
there are there are some some data sets
that you need to have at hand as a
snapshot and then you build your data so
you onboard that data product i'm sorry
your input data into your input folder
as i said there are some environment
variables that you promised that you
will be providing at the time of the
build so you set those promise
environment variables then there's this
step of dp input map so you run this
command dp input map
this is
a state step that we added with the
mindset of encouraging best practices
which in our mind is that if you have
some bulk of data
it
is beneficial to take a look before
sending everything over in some cases
you know that you want to send all of
the data that you have put in the input
folder over and that's easy in this case
of two example that's going to be the
case but in some cases you want to look
at some metadata you know are there
duplicate data are there names that
could clash
confusing you know elements there so
there's this step that uh you you you do
deep input map and you get all of that
metadata you take a look at it and you
pick the elements that you need to sync
then you call dp input sync by setting
those flag of what data sets you want to
sync
and this thing step could take a little
while right because at this point
literally you're pushing the data sets
one at a time your remote location
so if you have hundreds of those data
sets so depending on the size it could
take a little bit and this last step
you're doing dp input right which is
actually pretty fast because at this
point your date all of those input
datasets that you have synced are all
metadata code so you're just writing a
manifest so it's pretty quick
so at this point uh let's take a look
and see how this how this looks so
we we are just writing this uh cars data
set uh into the input folder
uh and
so that is our in the only input data
that we want to onboard into our data
product
uh next we are gonna activate the
project this assumes that there was a
gap between this initialization and then
this second step if you have already if
you want to go through all the way from
initialization you don't need to
activate again
then you set up those environment
variable that we promised so we set up
those environment variables and and then
we capture everything into this config
object
that has metadata all the elements that
we need to have at hand for the project
to to proceed uh
smoothly so
now at this point we only had one data
set so we do the input map
and then uh we
essentially know that we want to sync
this data there's nothing that we want
to exclude or change
so we just sync by calling dp input sync
now your data input data has been synced
this was pretty quick because it was
just a simple data
a small data set so you get a version
for that and uh now you're doing the
right and you're you're done at this
point so now you have converted you've
set up your project you've converted
your input into code onboarded that data
and now comes the part that you're going
to be building
um the data product itself going from
input to the output so this is the part
that you're going to be spending your
time bringing your subject matter
expertise to codify all the requirements
and all of the user stories that you
heard about
into code that does the logic of data
wrangling in our case it's very simple
right you know we have only changing one
column but in essence it's going to be
exactly the same every time so you have
dp input read which reads in all of the
input data that you have synced and
onboarded into your into your data
product
you add the wrangling logic then you
structure your data object uh there's
this function called dp structure that
the structure is the input the output
metadata all into one object then
similar to dp input write you are
registering that data as a metadata now
so again now your input was converted to
code now your output is also converted
to code and since everything is code you
do dp commit and dp push
and
at this point you have a repository
with with readme and you know all of the
documentation that you need to build
this data product from a scratch
your data product hasn't left your your
workstation but anybody who has access
to the repo can build it in their site
and and push it and including a ci cd
mission so
let's take a look to see how this goes
this is going to be super fast uh so you
read all of the data sets you added your
out logic made the output structured in
the data object and then you write it as
a yaml file and and then you you do the
dp commit and dp push and uh that will
generate your uh your repo so at this
point uh you are uh you know the work is
done as far as uh you know the data
developer is concerned
and the data can be built
but if you uh
if you wanted to deploy at this point
and you you don't have to for example
you may be able to commit push a bunch
of times until you get to a state that
your data product is at the state that
you want to push but let's say you are
at that stage and you're ready to push
so then you call this dp deploy function
which is a single function and it will
deploy deploy the data product for you
this may take again a little bit because
at this point you're also pushing your
data product uh to your remote location
depending on the size
but uh that essentially concludes the a
to z of building the data product now if
you want to access it from the persona
of a user
you only need these three commands dp
connect which logs into the library
uh that has all the data product dp list
it lists all the available data and
metadata and dp gets then you can pick
from from the list of data products that
you have available so let's take a look
at how this this works so dp deploy uh
deploys the data product it doesn't even
need any parameters at this point if you
have followed the steps as i described
um this was pretty quick because it was
a small data product then uh as a user
now you can access this library uh doing
uh dp connect um
and uh so now you're connected to that
library and then you can list the
content now
as the contents being less perhaps it's
worth taking a quick look at it it has a
lot of useful metadata like who
committed the data what was the commit
note uh what is the git sha uh that if i
needed to go back to the code uh how you
know how can i pull this specific code
and and a number of other metadatas uh
that that are uh of use
and lastly if you found your data
product that you want to pull you can
just pull that by version uh now
by convention what we have done is that
the data products uh uh input content we
keep it as what we call pin link
essentially it is a function called a
specific
version of the data that was integrated
so the data itself is not integrated
into the list that is the data object
the output since there are fewer of them
we always keep it as a data frame within
the data so here you see that i'm
pulling an input as a and it's a
function it's really a function call so
i put the input data and then i can put
that i can pull the output which is an
actual data frame connected to the to
the data
so
we've talked again about uh this
you know data product and what is
requirement but how does it feel how
does it look you know when you look at
it
the framework doesn't really impose any
specific uh um
you know uh
structure uh you can bring in your own
structure as you as you wish but by
convention this is kind of this uh
structure that we typically follow so by
convention we always start with you know
data product as dp and underscore
perhaps a project name and then some
particular topic that deals with perhaps
a branch of that data product
and we have input output metadata readme
you can have other options
so it's comprised of data frames
and functions that do various things a
family of functions that worth a mention
is this
pin link that i mentioned earlier so
let's say you have this data product
it's had some input you look at the
clinical component that you're
interested in the demographics and this
one at this leaf you have in the list
you really have a function called a
specific
version of this demographic data
so it's not part of your data
but you can pull it in as as needed
so what happens is typically we have
hundreds of these input data sets
and you know either all of them are
fairly decent size but the data product
itself the size of it is pretty small
because all of these are actual function
calls they are not they're not data by
convention since we have fewer of these
outputs we keep them as data frames so
you have data for analysis a data for
analysis p you have some metadata and
and read me and such
the output can absolutely also be
painlings if needed but
the need hasn't been there so far
so as you're thinking about this some
limitations and concentrate constraint
dapper deals with tabular data but does
not natively impose or accommodate
relational data models so that is
consideration dapper is not intended for
large data tables so if you have a bunch
of uh
smallish to medium-sized tables you know
hundreds of megabytes you have hundreds
of them totally fine if you have single
data tables that are gigantic uh
at this point we have some ideas how to
deal with it but it hasn't been part of
the use cases that
we have worked on and it's not supported
so dapper does not address data
governance i would be glad to talk a
little bit more about that but instead
of actually looking at this as a
shortcoming i look at this as an
opportunity for collaboration um across
across the team so you can work with the
data platforms that have a lot of knobs
and levers that allow granular access uh
being managed but
that is not part of the
elements that is managed by dapper
and most importantly dapper and packages
that it is built upon are very young so
dapper itself is
not that old and uh pins and rn which
are integral to its functionality are
also quite young
so in summary uh i'm hoping at this
point some of you
see some value and agree that with the
minimal amount of work which we showed
in those videos it you know it doesn't
take a whole lot of time you can take
your current data wrangling and trade it
up
to get a data product that comes with
all of those attributes
and guarantees that hopefully make
the experience of the user much more
pleasant and and builds efficiency
as well in
across the across the team
this is very much a project that we are
both heavily using as a consumer of this
framework but also we are developing and
a lot of the development falls along the
cycle of devops
but you know here we are having it for
data
to just mention some of these examples
of projects that we are working on so we
are working on an information-based
diffing of data uh this is a this is a
work that uh uh we had uh uh a great
colleague joining us for the summer uh
and and contributed to building this
ddif package
and
we also are
building uh vignettes around how to
automate
so ci cd uh you know set up uh data
testing is another element that we want
to kind of build vignettes around so how
folks can can integrate data testing
into the the workflow uh and
some work around adding additional
metadata to enable observability and
lastly uh something that is interesting
is that since data is recipe
you can spin it up and spin it down so
demand-based deployment could be
something that could help save storage
if that is ever
a concern so with that uh i just wanted
to take a moment again to
thank our pharma meetup organizers and
community
and i need to acknowledge the efforts of
a lot of colleagues who have contributed
thoughts ideas support uh one way or
another to to this project and
uh last but not least all of you for
tuning in today yeah i'd love to kind of
talk a little bit more and address some
questions
awesome thank you so much option let me
bring phil over here too
awesome i see
great that was a great presentation
thank you so much there are a lot of
questions starting to come in on slido
so i just want to remind everybody that
you can ask questions wherever you are
so if you're watching on
linkedin you can ask there and we'll see
them if you're on youtube live you can
ask there
or if you want to ask anything
anonymously you can use this slido link
here as well
and we can share that into the chat
because you can't click on it here
but one question that i see
over
on slido
was what's your best advice for
companies running into issues getting
approval to use open source
oh that's a that's a really good
question i think i'll just defer
that to
phil i think that's
so typically i mean i i would say for
that it usually starts with a champion
that helps to drive some successes uh
you know shiny is great for that because
it brings in some capabilities into the
organization but i mean most of the big
pharma's and small and even medium-sized
ones there's usually
a spark that starts with someone and
that and that helps create competency
centers or data science meetups or or
hangouts
they usually have a way for people to
get help and that just starts to
snowball into that but r is a great
language for starting off because you
can
have a lot of small little successes
that can really grow and that leads into
python and other languages stan and
javascript and and julia and so on so
um usually it starts with the right
person at the company driving for it and
uh rachel has done a lot of good work
helping those people with the champion
page so yeah
oh yeah i will share that in the chat
right now too
so if anybody is in that position
of introducing open source tools and
need just a little support
i
recently created this site called
rstudio.com champion but pulls together
a lot of resources from people like you
all um
who have spoke at meetups and hangouts
and just shares what people have been
doing
i realized phil
when you weren't on initially i didn't
actually introduce you so would be great
to have you introduced that's okay i was
i was running from a workshop so i was a
tiny bit late but uh yeah so i'm phil
i'm the director here of life sciences
and healthcare at our studio i and i
work with a lot of the groups in the
pharma space and yeah i remember last
year
um i saw this talk or a version of the
stock at r pharma and i absolutely was
blown away because i feel like there's
such a big impact right now from the
data science side and and and i feel
like the common thread among that is is
data wrangling data management
and you're seeing a lot of uh things
coming over from data science to helping
improve these processes so it's just a
great story and i think what you're
talking about is very applicable across
drug discovery research clinical trials
even post marketing other divisions of
the business i think it's a great
example of how data science can it can
really help across these areas so
fantastic work but anyway thank you
rachel so
yeah thank you and thank you so much
option i see somebody else asked on
slido if you had to guess what is your
team or company's mix of r python and
sas
this is uh
about dms that's uh
it's bms is a
very big organization as you know and uh
there are there are a lot of communities
uh within it so i my exposure is uh
to the
to the community that i am part of uh in
uh research and early development
informatica and predictive sciences and
we are heavy users of r at least from
the vantage point that i have uh
i would say
at least within within the within the
location that i am i would say perhaps
um
you know 70 plus uh
is is r and you know if you go to you
know the clinical side perhaps there's
more usage of
uh by clinical i mean i'm in research
and early developments more more data
science flavor then you have the uh
you know the uh clinical uh stats
departments that you know historically
as with in all pharma there's been more
uh more sas
and uh you know with some of the flavors
of machine learning i think more and
more folks are using python you know
julia is coming along
uh i i can't put a number on it uh how
many folks are using uh what percentage
but that's that's perhaps the best i can
provide
thank you yeah sure
um i see somebody had asked the question
over on linkedin and i i think this was
towards the very beginning
of the presentation but said when you
mentioned
the vanilla code is it possible to
discuss about it here
vanilla code uh i don't i can't recall
it
yeah so
i'll try to uh please chime in if uh if
i'm not addressing your question
so we do so the the code itself uh the
package itself generates code
uh so
it does provide some
template code when i talked about
blueprint so when you're starting your
project it populates your folder with
some base wiring that then you can you
can add to
i don't know if that's what you refer to
as the vanilla code or not or maybe i'm
but if that's that's the idea is that um
yeah so as as you're starting your
project uh
uh it does add uh it does add some um
some starter code for you to be able to
wire your project together
but i i have a feeling that doesn't
address the question yeah and we can
clarify on on linkedin too if that was
your question or on youtube people can
ask questions there too
i see there was another question on
slido
which is
how has it been implementing the data as
a product framework for a multilingual
team
does your environment support python and
r and do you use connect for this
yeah i really i really love this
question and because
it's one of the
one of the things that uh uh definitely
on my mind uh at this point it is
primarily an art right um
pins which is an awesome package so
shout out to the r studio developers for
pins
is at the core of uh of this dapper pins
is a package that supports both python
and python and
and r
and so the data products being pins
can be pulled in theory by by python as
well as r now when it comes to the
development like we are talking about an
end to end so we can get a recipe and
can build it up
of course that code is written in r of
course the packages are written in r so
in theory it is totally feasible uh to
to write our code in a way that
interfaces with python and uh
or or vice versa and cap or you know
have a sister package that essentially
uh manages that where the code itself if
you wanted to reproduce it not if you
wanted to use it as i said if you want
to just use it
you can absolutely
use the pins which is at the core of
this uh by python or r but if you're
developing it there is some dependency
on the environment that you're
developing on so um it can be done in in
theory but
perhaps it's better to kind of choose
where you want to be and in terms of
going back and forth again i think it's
feasible it's just a matter of
that development taking place at this
point
that hasn't been
done
a great question
thank you and i am just scrolling over
to see
if there are other questions and i'm not
seeing them pop up yet
but just want to turn it over to you
phil see if you have a general general
question you want to ask too
you know so many so many
thoughts around this
is it what's it like with new users
coming into this is there a certain type
of training is uh you know data is a
product and data wrangling and ci cd
i would say our newer methodologies
coming in um what's it like for people
coming to this new or we're used to
running these things more manually or in
like a batch mode
absolutely so um again i want to kind of
distinguish between folks coming to this
as a user or folks coming to this as a
developer so as a user yeah i think it's
pretty straightforward so the the kind
of ramp up to like okay this is the
data's library and i can pull and so
that that part is much easier and then
as a developer of course there's more
involved here right yeah
and i want to kind of
say that how critical this is and this
is one of the things that we have
learned since the first time uh you know
we presented on this
technology goes so far it is really
about this when it comes to these devops
practices it's really about culture it's
really about the collaboration
so it's been absolutely critical for us
to be able to forge those relations
uh and commitments and change in the
mindset of how we are doing data
so
it is a commitment it is something that
folks need to say okay you know i'm
going to commit
to being able to
or kind of like in carrying this cost
establishing my data infrastructure in
this way
and uh that commitment uh you know leads
to some changes in how like the question
of when the data is done
it is a parallel to question that when
when we are done and analyzing tcga for
example no one asks that question
because there's so many questions you
can ask from that data set
so
building that mental bridge and cultural
shift i think is is something that takes
time
from the technology perspective learning
the code and all of that i feel uh you
know someone going through it a couple
of times uh you know they will be able
to you'll be able to pick it up and one
learning again that we have had is that
it is really important for those in the
team who are a little bit more
experienced
to
uh lower the
kind of the entry barriers a little bit
so you bring in your wrangling code you
can work with your colleague to
integrate that into dapper and then from
that point on they can maintain it
so
it's a little bit of a commitment but uh
it's something that once folks made that
commitment i think uh within within a
course of a month or so you know they
can they can fully be
in this in this cycle of
of developing the data across a team
and first surfacing out the data and for
people
looking for and finding is there like a
data dictionary or a system or do they
go into an environment so someone says i
want this
assay data or this research data
how do they go about locating that yeah
absolutely so uh
building additional metadata that makes
the data set searchable is certainly
something that uh
there's room for to build additional
metadata at this point uh it
the
owner of the data you know folks who are
subject matter experts uh
are perhaps
the best people to connect with so if
you i'm saying it is absolutely possible
to put metadata out there but the
preferred route is uh you know a lot of
times folks want to just kind of go
fishing for data right and a lot of the
context may be missed so if if they have
specific questions and you know you work
within a team and you know like this
team actually owns a data product so
it's just a matter of having that
conversation up front and then that kind
of eases it in so
in a way they kind of like a global
world of metadata allow folks to kind of
like drill down and get exactly what
they want
it has been prioritized with respect to
like more personal connections on these
data products but absolutely doable to
add metadata
and do traditional data environments
like databases and uh
maybe even larger distributed data
sources does that also play into here or
is this more for
flat files or yeah no absolutely so we
uh
a data product uh in examples that we
have worked on brings in data from uh
diversity of sources so you may have a
traditional relational database uh that
there's a table you want so you bring
that in and then you augment it with a
table that you know you have curated
yourself of you know medications and the
classifications for example yeah yeah
so it does the the
key element is that
unlike some of these relational
unlike
some of these data repositories or data
platforms that are live data that could
change any time here we are snapchatting
so every time you're bringing it you're
taking a snapshot of that the state and
then you onboard it into your data
product
and do you have scheduling components
like if they say hey pull this every day
at 9am run this and then when the
scientists want to access the data it's
routinely updated with the new lab data
for example
yeah so that can absolutely be done uh
uh we we haven't had
the kind of automation of that as a use
case one of the things that we talked
about with our colleagues is that
the cadence of data products
is at a slower pace so if you have a
data set that you need to look at every
day perhaps
you don't spend a
huge amount of effort feature
engineering and all of those
uh elements if it's like if a single
patient coming in you know your your
statistics is not going to change uh it
is we are kind of going for like a
quarterly update to this data product we
are going deep
but the data evolution is kind of uh
is not that rapid
in theory you can absolutely do it right
you know you can just uh that could be
part of the code that the snapshot set
and then just kind of these data
products
i think it's something we see pretty
often with especially our developers the
idea of creating an etl job scheduling
that and the output of that being a data
product or a data set that then is fed
downstream into a machine learning model
or a shiny app for example right right
right yeah yeah no absolutely absolutely
i see there's a few other questions that
are coming through on slido i want to
make sure we go over to as well
but bond was
option could you explain more about
using promises to manage credentials
that will be needed in the user's
environment absolutely so everything
that is in a data product becomes code
right
um
including
the function calls
so if you need a
if you need to access something uh that
is behind some authentication layer
right
um
one way is to kind of provide that you
know password put it in the text and
then goes in your repo of course that is
a big no-no right so what we can do is
we can we can have a function called as
a text so imagine like you know if you
if it if if it is you know an
environment variable in r would be uh
cis.getn and there it is the environment
variable
uh
so these then become promises so you can
imagine and you have a configuration
file that tells where the data is and
what password you use to get to the data
it doesn't tell the exact password it
says run this command and that is the
promise that says when you run this
command this environment variable or
this key is going to be present in the
environment so that's why i mean by a
promise
hopefully that was clear
thank you
there's another um
question that i might reframe just a
little bit um to expand on it but it was
anonymous but it's
are there certain tools that you've
tried that
haven't worked well for your
requirements and
how did you
move towards getting the right tools
that you needed
so some is it in the context of
building these data products
[Music]
i think that that i think it might be in
the context of that it wasn't an
anonymous question but feel free to add
more context and slido anonymously too
yeah
so if i apologize if i'm not addressing
this uh but the tools that we have tried
that haven't quite done what uh we
wanted like one of them is the ddif uh
right so the idea of additive so right
now so the idea is if you're thinking
about your data and code to be kind of
interchangeable when you're writing a
code and you once and you commit it and
then someone says okay what's the
difference between this version and the
previous version uh you do uh you know
diff and get diff and it will tell you
like the lines of code that has changed
now imagine you have two columns of data
everything is multiplied by two
now every single element in the million
rows is gonna pop up as takes different
right you know you started with one one
becomes two but from information
perspective
nothing much has changed you know you
have just multiplied everything by a
factor so
um when we we would like to be able to
do the diff on the data side
that is as actionable as when you do the
div on the text side and if you want to
use the text based diff which are a lot
of good packages out there that does
that in r for you
uh you don't get that information based
you don't say that how the likelihood of
the data now has shifted so if you were
to say if you come up with a score that
says oh your data shifted by you know
point zero two you know i know that's
kind of uh perhaps a high bar but that
is an actionable things like i don't
need to run my ml uh you know model and
because my data barely changed versus
you know your data has changed you know
by by you know 95
right or some likelihood or something
that is you know tells you that your
data really shifted
so that is something that we are
developing now
and uh we did look at all of the things
are available out there and it wasn't
quite uh doing what we wanted but
perhaps i'm not answering that question
so please feel free to
ask again
or elaborate oh thank you that that's
really helpful
um yeah and again feel free to add more
contacts on slido if you want us to
expand on anything or ask questions in
youtube or linkedin
but after this question we were actually
just talking about this yesterday i know
someone said there's a supportive
community for open source and pharma
even though it's a competitive industry
other industries seem less open to
sharing why do you think that is
well
i think rachel probably you have
as much more insight than i do because
you go across industry but one thing i i
want to say i grew up in a
in biotech uh and more on the technology
side of the uh biomedical research so i
i watched for a while pharma and then i
joined and i was even back then i was
blown away by the generosity of pharma
for
putting code out there putting
algorithms even out there
i don't know exactly i kind of speak
like for universal pharma but i feel
like
everyone who is in pharma is really
really focused on patients lives
and
when you're thinking about those
medicines where you're thinking about
those uh chemistries and you know how we
are innovating uh on therapeutics that
is where
you know a lot of uh you know
sensitivity and you know desire is to
innovate right
and there's a huge amount of generosity
when it comes to algorithms that are
not the core offering of this pharma so
if this helps the industry
they put it out there again a specific
example me working in a biotech was that
i was working with an algorithm that
could be monetized because it would help
with patient selection but uh
the pharma that uh was we were working
on just open sources you know you guys
want to make a product out of it go
right ahead so so that is my my
impression but yeah i i don't know how
you address this rachel
no no that's a great great answer
i think it's been
really powerful to see all the community
initiatives around pharma and phil can
speak much more to this but also
like seeing everybody coming together
for r and pharma or starting off small
working groups and and getting to grow
that i think really helps make it what
it is so there's these it seems like
there's so many leaders around the
pharma space who are just kind of taking
an idea and running with it and getting
people to
to work together which is amazing
i think you had the nail on the head
it's it's inspiring work and i mean
we're creating medicine and helping
people's lives and i mean i i think
everybody personally or or through
family members have been impacted i know
i have been and i i i love the industry
and i i love supporting it
i've i've felt this way since since day
one being involved in it and um i i
think too there's a strong back
ground to the academia space and there's
a lot of research that comes out of that
and it carries over into the ecosystem
which is also helps to create some of
the culture and the excitement for
research
but yeah it's
it's a great space to support so yeah
our rn pharma has been awesome for this
is another really awesome space
um you know and it just it's amazing to
see groups like
astrazeneca and other groups pfizer for
example they have very large
bms as well i mean celgene ian wallace
and isaac newhouse and all the awesome
people that you work with right um you
know there's there's amazing groups
within these farmers that are also very
big and thriving and and focused on
collaboration and
on community and discussing these types
of topics and it's all for that that
single mission that that you first spoke
about so yeah
yeah thank you so much for all that you
do and and for sharing with the
community and in an event like this as
well
i see there a few other questions i know
we just hit the top of the hour do you
have a few more minutes
absolutely okay
awesome
i see carlos said great presentation
things just curious does this data as
code and code as data paradigm have
something to do with the so-called list
like functional approach to code which i
will say i don't know what that is so
that would be great to
understand as well yeah
that is uh if it does
it would be one of those cases that you
know perhaps we'll learn about it
because i i am also not
uh
familiar with
exactly the parallel between um first of
all i have no lisp experience so to put
it out there
and
i
in terms of functional programming
i don't know if this answers the
question it are being a functional
programming uh you know language as
opposed to an object-oriented uh by
nature right uh it's a math-based
language right uh
the the the
framework
actually highly encourages
by using uh some of you know the package
drake um
has been converted to targets it
actually builds uh the data recipes
based on drake where everything is
converted to a function so all of the
dangling essentially becomes function
and individual individual scripts
so it encourages functional programming
but i don't know
if it addresses the question about the
lisp-like functional approach so yeah
maybe reach out and then we can we can
talk more about it
it's awesome to hear uh
using targets uh will does awesome work
with that package and that package is
gold
oh yeah
option i i realize i forgot to share
your
link to your github as well
but i wanted to pull that up on the
screen here too
and again uh speaking of kind of the
openness of pharma i
kind of shout out to my employer in this
case
uh which you know when we put it out
there i said yeah you can open source
this so it is now in my uh in my github
repo but it really is out in the open so
i really appreciate anyone
uh you know looking at the code having
ideas if you would like to collaborate
uh
uh yeah just much much appreciate
thoughts ideas criticism anything that
you
you can bring
that will
make this uh
more hopefully more useful
it's very interesting because in the the
late stage phase there's there's kind of
a not really
not kind of there's actually a strong
movement happening right now to bring
and consolidate and
qualify some of the core packages used
for clinical called the pharmaverse be
interesting to see if something similar
happens like within the packaging that
you're talking about it has already to a
large degree for genomics with
bioconductor but uh
it's it's amazing that people are
starting to take packages and bring them
together into more cohesive
ecosystems well absolutely i mean i
think that would be i i've meant to kind
of explore that foreign words a little
bit more and i love that idea i mean one
thing that i would share it's kind of an
insight
when you do this i i'm a statistician by
training so i come to this data
management tool sets world from
from that around
and and you know in my head you know
initially there's this data world and
then there's the analysis world
but it is one continuum like let's say
you do an analysis you come up with an
inference table that is new data that
you can tag along to your data products
or and so there's the distinction
between analysis and data it just blends
together so having our support from uh a
to z here uh and being all in one
language and you don't have to you know
bring in five different uh you know
set off languages and expertise together
i think it's really powerful
in terms of reproducibility in terms of
folks being able to have
ability to go across and check the work
so
yeah yeah do you see shiny being a part
of that and consuming some of these data
products or surfacing them out
absolutely i mean i i think uh i i i
just when you when you zoom out you see
this uh vista that you have yeah data
and inference and then shiny is like a
user interface for all of it so one
thing that is very very relevant to
shiny and i would say our studio connect
we are uh we are heavily using that
because
what happens is this data product i
shared uh
at the end of the day it's a
programmatic uh accessible object it
needs to have if you want to collaborate
with that you know colleague of yours
who has tremendous amount of information
on the biology or on the clinical side
they want to be able to interface that
through a user interface uh so we build
these automated reports that brings in
the data products and surfaces
so so you know the the mds and you know
the uh the biologists can can really dig
deep and then feedback say okay go ahead
and change your data so then this
becomes part of that devops cycle so the
data itself iterates and we're we're
getting all of that feedback through
shiny through the
our markdowns and the interface between
the two of them
if it's okay so what was it like going
from
you know statistics statistician type
work to so much data wrangling data
engineering data i mean it's such a
awesome area that you're working in now
and what was that transition like for
you yes yeah i know absolutely i mean uh
what really is so i started my career as
an engineer no no data
i was building hardware
and then i saw data i was like i gotta
get my hand so i i went and got uh uh
you know training biostatistics yeah and
then once i was working uh developing
algorithms
i i started building uh so i was
developing uh algorithms for um
you know kind of data mining on publicly
available data and building
signature i realized that
what really matters and this is
something that we are hearing in the
concept of data centric ai particularly
in biomedical research
if you were to earn the dollar
if you spent 70 cents of that dollar on
data and 30 cents of that on on you know
your new fancy algorithms that is coming
you would be much better off than doing
it the other way around there's a lot of
a lot of value to be
uh you know kind of retrieved from the
data work so that is really what drew me
into more and more
and and i think that is
a bio like if you think about a role of
data in biological data
compare that to click data that is maybe
in the industry of you know when you
think about you know other other uh
other industries outside bio that row of
data could worth you know hundreds of
thousands of dollars
so
uh in terms of actual and if you can't
put a dollar value on it so it's super
precious
so
effort on the data uh for me was that
awakening like i i am doing this a
statistic machine learning algorithm
development yeah but
if i if i can shift my focus a little
bit towards the data you know there's it
is uh
there's a lot of ripe opportunities
there's so much excitement in the space
right now and you're mentioning
algorithms around you know
deep learning ai first principles
impacting especially drug discovery um
are you seeing and being part of that
too as well right now
no absolutely i mean there's there's
tremendous amount of uh excitement about
ai in all industries and and you know
pharma is no exception
particularly when it comes to you know
uh
new therapeutics being developed using
ai and all of that i personally i'm not
part of part of that effort uh but what
i've seen you know as someone who has
come from uh that background of a
statistics machine learning is that um
there is a lot of excitement on that ai
front rightly so
but i would say there is room to get a
lot more excited about the data itself
so i think i think andre inc has this uh
really cool uh um
you know set of ideas about you can you
can you can iterate on your model a
bunch of times
and you go you know this far you can
iterate on your data and you go this far
so so that is something that i feel
particularly in biofuel needs a little
bit more effort and all of those cool
algorithms that you use on the
learning side yes can actually be
applied to the data side um a lot of the
a lot of unsupervised learning
algorithms are have tremendous value on
the data side so
um so i see an opportunity more and more
for for focusing on that that area
the data is the common thread throughout
all of that
do you also get involved on the the
massive data side like the large
data sources uh spark hdfs things like
that does that come up much with the
data engineering side of it um
it well we do have massive data that
comes along
and uh
in the context that i have been involved
uh for machine learning purposes
a lot of uh a lot of the data informal
uh we are not very long data we are wide
data yeah
trial could have 100 folks 100 people
and it could be hundreds of millions of
dollars so you have for that one patient
you know millions of attributes that
you're collecting uh so a lot of the i
think a lot of the machine learning a
lot of algorithms uh typically
have been in the realm of being able to
address high dimensional data
and you know in the industry where you
have very long data you know folks using
spark and others there's absolutely it's
it hasn't been in my experience so i'm
sure it's in like other you know
colleagues within within my company are
leveraging that but in the world that i
am part of uh um our big data has been
the wide data uh yeah yeah lots of lots
of stuff well i can keep going on all
day
no i love this
i i did want to bring it back to the
community um
for a second here because i see babu
asks a great question
um he's a babu's in the early phase of
rna sequencing data analysis and need
some support and engagement with a
similar community
what is the best way for someone who's
new to the community to get involved and
where should they go
for this one i mean i i think a clear
one is uh the the bio conductor space is
a really big and opening
opening community as well as they have a
great conference i think i've even come
to it in new york city believe it or not
i think it was at a university in
new york so
um i would check that out if you're not
familiar with it r and pharma also has
some capabilities to connect with others
in the rna sync there's we kind of mix
it throughout all of the drug
development phases
but yeah do you have others that you
would suggest
you're probably definitely more closer
to the community on that and than i am
but anything come to mind
yeah i was i was trying to find the link
for
some of the upcoming meetups or like
local meetup groups too but sometimes
it's hard to do two things once here so
i will definitely share those links with
the recording as well
but i would say also just
getting in touch and meeting people at
some of the other our studio community
events as well i would i'm always happy
to try and help connect people there's
so many other community
events and programs that i don't yet
know about that i'm just learning about
all the time
one
great place to to meet people is every
thursday at our studio we host the data
science hangout and so this is
at noon eastern time every thursday and
we have a different featured leader from
the community who comes on and answers
questions and you get to meet everybody
else who's there and ask questions i'd
say that's a great place to to ask this
question too and and i can ask that to
them as well
but this link here is a calendar of all
the upcoming community events as well
i'm gonna do one last check here to see
if there are any
questions that i miss and if i have
missed your question feel free to ask it
again on linkedin or youtube so i don't
miss anything
awesome
thank you
yeah
thank you so much ashton for such a
great presentation and i just want to
call out again your your github link
here
uh in just a second
so if people have suggestions or want to
work together with you is that the the
best place to go
absolutely so if you if you want to
engage at the code level or if you have
ideas
feel free to uh you know create an issue
or you know kind of um if you have pull
requests or otherwise you know
definitely uh this is an active area of
development i'll keep an eye on it uh
if you needed to get in touch with me on
other subjects that are relevant to this
uh
that may not be
you know so tied to the code uh
you know feel free to find me on on
linkedin uh message me um and yeah i
would be i'd be happy to to follow up
awesome well thank you all so much thank
you option and thank you all for the
great questions as well and being here
with us today
yep one last thing i'll add is that i
think this is actually our seventh uh
installment of our life sciences series
so you can find uh the past one we had
with merck we've done some with roche
uh novaris and so on so it's wonderful
to add
bms to that list and
keep up the awesome work
now thank you so much for creating this
space and uh
fostering that spirit of you know
collaboration i really appreciate it
thank you so much rachel thanks a lot
phil yeah i i'm a i was just telling
rachel before this i followed the last
week's installments uh with fda
functional data uh analysis uh
and and all of them are awesome so thank
you so much for for creating this space
and uh and yeah just kind of allowing
knowledge to be shared
absolutely thank you have a great rest
of the day everybody